.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich hatte mich damals nur
auf den Drogenhandel konzentriert.
Das ist eines der ekligsten
und dreckigsten Business,
die es überhaupt gibt.
In dem Business
hält man nicht die Hand hin
und bittet um das Geld.
Da hält man ihm
eine Waffe ins Gesicht.
Kriegt man das Geld nicht, hält man
sie seiner Ehefrau ins Gesicht.
Von Saulus zu Paulus:
Ilias Schori
kam mit 14 auf die schiefe Bahn
und landete mit 23 im Gefängnis.
Heute klärt er über die Folgen
von Jugendkriminalität auf.
Es ist nie ein schönes Gefühl,
davon erzählen zu müssen.
Ich habe
keine schönen Dinge gemacht.
Ich schäme mich
natürlich auch dafür.
Aber ich erzähle es
irgendwie auch gerne,
um diesen jungen Menschen zu zeigen,
dass das der falsche Weg ist.
Ilias Schori
vor einem Aufklärungseinsatz,
zusammen mit der Geschäftsführerin
des Vereins
"Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen"
und seinem Hund Miele.
Das Schulhaus
von Rorbas-Freienstein-Teufen
kennt Ilias Schori gut.
C ...
Dann muss das A sein.
Schori ist hier zur Schule gegangen.
Doch seine Schulzeit endete in der
1. Oberstufe mit einem Rausschmiss.
Ich habe das von zu Hause
mit an die Schule genommen,
die Missstände,
die dort halt bestanden.
Und ich habe das hier rausgelassen.
Dazumal suchte ich die Schuld
immer bei den Lehrern.
Heute kann ich
reflektierter darüber denken
und weiss genau,
dass ich mitschuldig bin.
Ilias Schoris kriminelle Laufbahn
nahm hier ihren Anfang
und sie endete im Gefängnis.
Ich glaube, das ist A.
Ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Guten Morgen miteinander,
ich bin Andrea Thelen.
Ich bin Geschäftsführerin
und Initiantin
des Projekts
"Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen".
Ilias Schori ist Projektleiter.
Er führt euch nachher
durch den Morgen.
Worum geht es?
Dass Jugendliche, die
etwas mit der Kriminalität spielen -
also ein bisschen Drogen,
Gewalt, Mobbing -,
früher oder später
ins Gefängnis kommen.
Ja, hoi miteinander. Seid ihr fit?
* Murmeln *
Ja?
Ausgeschlafen?
Ja ...
Das kenne ich. Könnte besser sein.
Aber wir packen den Morgen.
Ich bin Ilias Schori, jetzt noch 29.
In zehn Tagen bin ich 30.
Ich bin glücklich,
dass ich mit meinen 30 Jahren
hier vor euch stehen darf.
Das ist speziell: Ich sass mal hier.
Ich ging hier zur Schule.
Warum ich schlussendlich
knapp fünf Jahre im Gefängnis sass,
erzähle ich euch an diesem Morgen.
Sein Weg in die Delinquenz begann
mit regelmässigem Cannabiskonsum.
Man wird verhängt, man macht nicht
mehr richtig in der Schule mit.
Man bringt
keine richtige Leistung mehr.
Man kann irgendwann
nicht mehr einschlafen.
Ich musste am Abend
drei Joints rauchen.
Morgens rauchte ich auch einen
und schlief in der Schule fast ein,
weil ich so bekifft war.
Das muss man sich
auch irgendwie finanzieren.
Kriegt ihr Taschengeld?
Sehr nett von euren Eltern.
Ich kriegte keines.
Wo holt man sich das also?
Man muss es klauen.
Ich stahl aus den Portemonnaies
meiner Eltern
oder versuchte beim Dealer
direkt was zu stehlen.
Man kommt in eine Spirale rein,
in der man auch skrupelloser wird.
So driftet man
langsam aber sicher ab.
Meine schulische Leistung
wurde immer schlechter,
zu Hause stank es nach Gras,
also wurde ich noch mehr verprügelt.
Schlussendlich wurde ich
in der 1. Oberstufe rausgeworfen.
Ich habe bis heute
keinen Oberstufenschulabschluss.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Seit vier Jahren
ist Ilias Schori auf freiem Fuss
und lebt seither
in einer kleinen Mietwohnung.
Seine Delikte:
Hausfriedensbruch, Drohung, Verstoss
gegen das Betäubungsmittelgesetz,
Sachbeschädigung, Raub, banden-
und gewerbsmässiger Diebstahl.
Drei Jahre sass er dafür in
der Justizvollzugsanstalt Pöschwies.
Heute arbeitet Schori
in einem 80-%-Pensum
für den Verein
"Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen".
Wenn man Ihre Aussicht sieht ...
... fühlt man sich wie im Gefängnis.
- Ja.
Das ist irgendwie paradox:
Der Einbrecher
zieht in eine Wohnung,
in der er sich wie hinter Gittern
fühlt - wegen des Einbruchschutzes.
Da oben steht "Home".
Was bedeutet Ihnen
die eigene Wohnung? - Viel.
Ganz ehrlich, ich fühlte mich
lange nicht zu Hause hier.
Ich habe mich
nie irgendwo zu Hause gefühlt.
Ich hatte so viele Wechsel ...
Ich war nie irgendwo zu Hause.
Das Zuhause
verbinde ich mit dem Ort,
wo ich Ruhe habe
und zu mir kommen kann.
Mittlerweile ist das mein Zuhause.
Ein Teil meiner Freiheit, absolut.
Ich schätze, dass ich
ein eigenes Dach über dem Kopf habe.
Dass ich mich
durch meine Arbeit finanzieren kann.
Das gebe ich
so schnell nicht mehr her.
Sie haben wenige Sachen.
- Nein, ich habe ...
Ich hatte ja nichts,
als ich aus dem Gefängnis kam.
Ich hatte eine Tasche
mit ein paar Kleidern, nicht mehr.
Das Bett habe ich mir gekauft.
Ich könnte nirgends schlafen, worin
schon mal Leute geschlafen haben.
Das reichte mir
im Heim und im Gefängnis.
Da bin ich zu hygienisch.
Darum habe ich das Bett und das Sofa
als einziges neu gekauft.
Den Rest habe ich geschenkt bekommen
oder Occasion gekauft.
Anfangs hatte ich natürlich
null finanzielle Mittel.
Ilias Schori sitzt auf einem
Schuldenberg von über 100'000 Fr.,
den er noch mind. zehn Jahre lang
abbezahlen muss.
Schneller schuldenfrei
wäre er ohne seinen Strassenhund
Miele aus Sizilien.
Doch ein Leben ohne Miele
ist für Schori undenkbar.
High five. Ja, fein.
Kuss geben. Mhm.
Miele hat eine besondere Bedeutung
für Sie, oder?
Ja. Er ist mein bester Freund.
Er hält seine Klappe, wenn ich
nach Hause komme, freut sich aber.
Hm?
Er ist sehr vorsichtig.
Ich kann es ihm so geben.
"Führe mich nicht in Versuchung"
hat sich Schori
auf seine beiden Hände tätowiert.
Denn die Versuchung lauert überall.
Anfangs, als ich rauskam,
hatte ich einen Freund ...
Ich dachte, er hätte es geschafft.
Er holte mich zu Hause ab,
weil wir etwas trinken wollten.
Er hatte mich nicht vorgewarnt,
öffnete die Mittelkonsole
und da lagen 500 g Kokain
und 500 g Heroin drin.
Und ich sagte: "Spinnst du?
Du fährst so mit mir rum?"
Da merkte ich,
wie skrupellos diese Leute sind.
Er hat mir nichts gesagt,
sonst wäre ich nicht eingestiegen.
Ich merkte, dass ich
von all den Leuten weg musste.
Dass ich nur so
aus diesen Kreisen rauskomme.
Und das machte ich auch.
Ich kam nie in Versuchung bis jetzt.
Nie.
Nie mehr in Versuchung gekommen,
etwas ...
... ein Delikt zu begehen?
Warum nicht?
Ich habe keine Lust.
Ich habe die Schnauze voll.
Ich bin müde.
Ich habe in diesen 15 Jahren
so viel gemacht ...
Ab meinem 12., 13. Lebensjahr
bis und mit 23 oder 24
ist so viel passiert ...
Das erleben gewisse Leute
in ihrem ganzen Leben nicht.
Das macht irgendwann müde.
Diese On-off-Beziehung
mit dem Gefängnis und den Heimen.
Überall einbrechen,
man ist überall unterwegs ...
Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Ich will nach Hause kommen und ohne
schlechtes Gewissen ins Bett liegen.
Und ruhig schlafen. Ja.
Woran ich vielleicht mal denke,
wenn ich ein Bier zu viel trinke,
ist ein Schnupf oder so.
Kokain?
- Ja.
Das hat aber nichts
mit kriminell sein zu tun.
Aber ich konnte zum Glück
auch da die Finger davon lassen.
Ilias Schoris Eltern
liessen sich scheiden, als er 13 war.
Er verlor den Halt,
geriet an die falschen Freunde,
kiffte, schwänzte die Schule.
Was folgte,
war eine ruinierte Jugend:
Heimaufenthalte, Pflegefamilien,
Leben auf der Kurve
und in Jugendgefängnissen.
In über 20 Institutionen lebte Schori
bis zu seinem 18. Lebensjahr.
Ich fragte mich:
"Was läuft falsch mit euch?"
Ich fühlte mich
verraten und verlassen von allen:
von meinen Familienmitgliedern
und sonstigen Erwachsenen.
Ich entwickelte ein heftiges
Feindbild gegen Pädagogen
und alle Erwachsenen,
die dort arbeiteten.
Sie nannten eine Regel,
z.B. dass ich etwas nicht durfte ...
Kleinste Trigger reichten,
dass ich Sachen kaputtmachte.
Am Anfang seiner Tätigkeit im Verein
habe er jeden Abend zu Hause geweint,
erinnert sich Schori.
Schuld- und Schamgefühle
plagten den ehemaligen Häftling.
Eine Psychotherapie
ist deshalb unabdingbarer Bestandteil
seiner Arbeit im Verein
"Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen".
Trotzdem: Die Aufarbeitung
des Erlebten bleibt schmerzhaft.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Sind Sie Opfer oder Täter?
Beides.
In erster Linie bin ich sicher ...
Also, Opfer oder Täter ...
Ja, in erster Linie bin ich Täter.
Und damit machte ich mich
zum Opfer in meinem eigenen Leben.
Weil ich mich dazu entschied,
diese Taten zu begehen,
muss ich heute damit leben,
dass ich hinterherhinke
und gewisse Dinge nicht erreichen
konnte, die andere haben.
Und
auf die Kindheit runtergebrochen:
Jedes Kind ist ein Opfer, wenn das
Familiensystem nicht funktioniert.
Das ist Fakt.
Ein Kind kann nicht überlegen.
Dafür sind die Eltern,
Lehrer und Leute rundherum da.
Also jene, die
als Erziehungsberechtigte gelten.
Die sind dafür verantwortlich.
Wenn man will, kann man sagen,
dass ich da ein Opfer war.
Aber im Endeffekt war ich
während meines Erwachsenwerdens,
so ab 14, 15, 16
und rauf bis schlussendlich 23, 24,
natürlich ein Täter.
Mit 15 Jahren wurde Ilias Schori
ins AHBasel eingewiesen,
eine Durchgangsinstitution
für männliche Jugendliche.
* Klingeln *
Du musst von der Tür wegkommen.
Mach Sitz.
- (Mann) AHBasel.
Guten Tag. Ilias Schori.
Wir haben einen Termin
mit Frau Denz. - Ja, Moment, bitte.
* Klicken *
Hallo miteinander.
Tschau. Sali.
- Hallo. Hoi. Wie geht es dir?
Es ist gerade etwas anstrengend.
- Anstrengend?
Der Institutionsleiterin
begegnet Schori heute auf Augenhöhe.
Eine Kehrtwende wie er sie in
den letzten Jahren durchlaufen hat,
hätte ihm hier niemand zugetraut.
Frau Denz,
welche Erinnerungen kommen rauf,
wenn Sie Ilias wiedersehen?
Erinnerungen ...
Er war ein schwieriger,
schwieriger Jugendlicher.
Schwierig?
- Ja.
Besonders schwierig?
Schwieriger als der Durchschnitt?
Du darfst absolut ehrlich sein.
Ich würde sagen, er war einer
der schwierigsten Fälle - wegen ...
... all deiner Belastungen.
Wir waren schon das x-te Heim, oder?
- Ja.
Ich weiss nicht, das wievielte.
Ich glaube, das ...
Was das Belastendste für alle ist:
wenn die Eltern nicht da sind.
Wenn man niemanden mehr hat, der
an einen glaubt und einen besucht.
Ich erinnere mich
auch nicht mehr an alles.
Ich hatte es auch gut mit einigen.
Er hatte wahrscheinlich das Vertrauen
in die Welt total verloren.
Ja, schon vorher.
- Würde ich sagen. - Ja.
Ja.
- Ja.
Ilias Schori war in der geschlossenen
Abteilung des AHBasel untergebracht.
Verändert hat sich hier wenig.
Und die Ohnmachtsgefühle überwältigen
Schori auch Jahre später wieder.
Das da draussen
war mein Lieblingsort.
Da konnte man Fussball spielen.
Ich spielte immer Fussball.
Das lässt sich nicht heben.
Alles ist festgemacht.
Im Eintrittszimmer
konnte man das Bett heben.
Ich weiss noch, dass ich das nahm
und damit auf die Tür einschlug,
bis sie völlig zerkratzt war.
Wahrscheinlich geht es darum,
dass man es als Waffe nutzen kann.
Man kann es demolieren,
und das will niemand.
Worauf waren Sie denn so wütend?
Auf alles und jeden.
Einfach ... Ich weiss nicht.
V.a. auf Erwachsene.
Ich verstand nicht,
warum ich eingesperrt wurde.
Ich konnte wohl nicht einsehen,
dass ich auch Fehler gemacht hatte.
Ich wollte einfach draussen sein.
Ja.
Ich wollte weg. Ich wollte raus.
Ich wollte nicht hier sein.
Ich hatte draussen niemanden,
zu dem ich hätte gehen können,
war hier aber auch allein.
Obwohl ich Leute hatte, die ja
nichts Schlechtes für mich wollten.
Es geht Ihnen nahe,
dass Sie hier sind. - Mhm.
Ja.
Jugendkriminalität verläuft
in Wellen, erzählt mir Anette Denz.
Seit 2016 ist sie wieder am Steigen.
Und die Täter werden immer jünger.
Ja,
wir haben einen Zwölfjährigen hier.
Der hat schon
diverse Raubüberfälle gemacht.
Das ist jetzt schon
der zweite oder dritte.
Ja, in dem Alter ...
Aus meiner Erfahrung ist es
schwieriger, da zu intervenieren.
Das ist alles
noch spannend und abenteuerlich.
Diese Gleichgültigkeit und
Konsequenzen nicht abschätzen können
ist in diesem Alter noch aus-
geprägter als bei 16-, 17-Jährigen.
Was macht man mit solchen Kindern?
Gute Frage. Ich weiss es nicht.
Ähm ...
Bei denen, die bei uns waren,
weiss ich,
dass da Familien dahinterstehen ...
... die nicht in der Lage sind,
ihre Kinder zu erziehen.
Also, da passiert relativ schnell
so eine Hierarchieumkehr
und dann bestimmen die Jungs.
Prävention wäre
bereits im Kindesalter notwendig.
Bei Ilias Schori gab es diese nicht,
und später schafften es alle
Sozialpädagoginnen und -pädagogen
in geschlossenen
und offenen Institutionen nicht mehr,
ihn auf den richtigen Weg zu bringen.
Mit 23 landete er im Gefängnis.
Und hier begann seine Wandlung.
Ich war sechs Monate
in Untersuchungshaft
und wurde schlussendlich zu etwas
mehr als 40 Monaten verurteilt.
Drei Jahre
musste ich davon absitzen -
u.a. im grössten Hochsicherheits-
gefängnis der Schweiz,
in der JVA Pöschwies in Regensdorf.
Man kommt da rein
und da sind 420 Schwerverbrecher.
Die Schlimmsten der Schlimmen. Ja.
Da wurde mir klar,
dass das nicht mein Leben sein kann.
"Will ich hier enden?"
"Ich habe eine absehbare Strafe
und komme relativ jung wieder raus."
"Entweder nutze ich die Chance oder
ich kann mich gleich aufhängen."
Sein Gesinnungswandel zeichnete sich
aber schon vor der Verurteilung ab.
Ich ging nach Einbrüchen
oft in den Ausgang.
Wenn halt gut Geld reingekommen war,
ging ich raus,
kaufte neue Kleider,
ging gross und gut essen,
haute im Ausgang auf den Putz ...
Am Schluss ging ich
nach den Einbrüchen direkt ins Bett.
Ich hatte keine Lust auf nichts.
Ich wusste, dass ich ein Idiot war.
Aber ich brauchte es irgendwie,
dass man mich verhaftet.
Das schlechte Gewissen kam dann
langsam aber sicher schon auf.
Ich habe heute noch
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Die Schuldgefühle sind da.
Aber ich habe gelernt, dass ich mich
davon nicht auffressen lassen darf.
Ich kann es nicht rückgängig machen,
sondern nur das Beste daraus machen.
Was sagen Sie,
wenn jemand Opfer geworden ist -
vielleicht sogar von Ihnen -,
das hier sieht und findet:
"Ja,
habe nur ein schlechtes Gewissen."?
Dann sage ich:
"Ja, da hast du recht."
"Entschuldigung dafür,
was ich gemacht habe." So ist es.
Mit seiner Arbeit für den Verein
"Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen"
wolle er der Gesellschaft
etwas zurückgeben,
was er einzelnen Opfern
genommen habe, sagt Ilias Schori.
Besuchen wir Dora?
Ja, hallo.
- Er ist etwas ängstlich.
Ja, er hat etwas Angst. Hoi, Ilias.
- Hoi, Dora. Hoi.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
- Es ist schon lange her.
Wie geht es?
- Ja, gut.
Kommt rein.
Durch seine Arbeit
lernte Ilias Schori Dora Senn kennen,
die auf schrecklichste Art und Weise
zum Opfer eines Gewaltverbrechens
wurde.
Ilias Schori
hat nichts mit dieser Tat zu tun.
Der Mord im Zürcher Seefeld
erschütterte 2016 die Öffentlichkeit:
Ein Insasse der JVA Pöschwies
ermordete auf Hafturlaub
einen 43-jährigen Mann.
Ein Zufallsopfer, um einen anderen
Gefängnisinsassen freizupressen.
Das Mordopfer: Dora Senns Sohn Marco.
Ich finde, dass man grundsätzlich
zu wenig für die Opfer macht.
Man überlässt sie sich selber
und denkt,
die würden den Weg
dann schon finden.
Es gibt welche,
die den Weg nie finden.
Nie.
Dora Senn
wollte Ilias Schori kennenlernen,
weil sie
von seinem Werdegang beeindruckt war.
Zwischen den beiden
ist eine Freundschaft entstanden.
Ich habe ja nichts
mit dieser Tat zu tun.
Aber weil ich mit solchen Menschen
eingesperrt war,
und weil ich selber
schlechte Dinge getan hatte ...
Das macht es nicht einfach ...
... der Mami eines Mordopfers
gegenüberzustehen.
Ich bin nicht mitschuldig,
schäme mich aber für die Sachen,
die ich gemacht habe.
Ich habe niemanden getötet
oder schwer verletzt,
aber ich habe den Leuten
durch meinen Mist Geld weggenommen,
durch das Dealen mit Drogen
andere süchtig gemacht ...
Ja, das löst einfach allgemein
ein gewisses Schamgefühl aus.
Jugendkriminalität
ist kein neues Phänomen.
Menschen delinquieren am allermeisten
zwischen 15 und 20 Jahren -
in allen Gesellschaften,
zu jeder Zeit.
Es gilt: Wenige Jugendliche zeichnen
für viele Straftaten verantwortlich.
Im Jugendalter ist es besonders
verbreitet, kriminell zu sein.
2,5 % der Jugendlichen
sind polizeilich registriert.
D.h.: 97,5 %
sind nicht polizeilich registriert.
Viele junge Menschen wissen,
was richtig und was falsch ist.
Und das heisst nicht,
dass jene, die registriert werden,
das nicht wissen.
Die wurden mal mitgerissen.
Wir wissen, dass Freundesgruppen
eine grosse Rolle spielen.
Sie wollen das
auch mal ausprobieren.
Ein Grossteil der jungen Menschen
ist auf einem guten Weg.
Vor Fachleuten in Luzern
erzählt Ilias Schori
aus seinem Leben
und von seiner Aufklärungsarbeit
für den Verein
"Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen".
Man muss Prävention
als etwas Aufwendiges einstufen.
Prävention funktioniert nicht
durch einen Videofilm,
oder
durch eine Stunde in der Schule,
in der man
über seine Biografie spricht.
Prävention ist etwas Dauerhaftes.
Man muss den jungen Menschen
Kompetenzen vermitteln,
damit sie sich
alternativ verhalten können
und z.B.
nicht immer gleich zuschlagen.
Und das braucht Zeit.
Diese Form von Prävention
wird nur erreicht,
wenn das ein Baustein
eines grösseren Programms ist.
Also, dass auch mal ein
ehemaliger Häftling etwas erzählt.
Aber das muss Teil
eines viel umfassenderen, kompetenz-
vermittelnden Programms sein.
Unser Projekt ist nicht
in erster Linie Prävention,
sondern Aufklärung.
Aufklärung
ist wie eine Stufe vorher.
Es braucht die Aufklärung, um später
Prävention machen zu können.
Aufklärung ist sehr wichtig,
damit man weiss,
worum es in der Kriminalität geht
und welches die Konsequenzen sind.
Was danach passiert,
bei einer richtigen Intervention ...
Da würde ich Herrn Baier zustimmen,
dass es da Beziehungsarbeit braucht
und das über längere Zeit geht.
Das ist aber nicht die Aufgabe
von "Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen".
Ich kam mit zwei anderen Insassen
zur Erkenntnis:
"Hey, ich habe in meiner Heimzeit
viele Jugendliche kennengelernt,
bei denen es - wie auch bei mir -
in der Familie angefangen hat."
Und ja,
ich war eigentlich mal glücklich.
Ich wuchs relativ normal auf.
Da war ich noch etwas dicker
und hatte noch Locken.
Sie nannten mich immer "Patata",
die frechen Kerle.
Das heisst "Kartoffel"
auf Italienisch.
Da hatte ich meine Mami
auch noch lieb.
So böse das klingt.
Mittlerweile
mag ich sie wieder mehr,
als das mal
in der Zwischenzeit der Fall war.
Ilias Schori ist als zweitältestes
von sechs Kindern aufgewachsen.
Mehr will er mir über seine Kindheit
nicht erzählen.
Nur, dass es schwierig war.
Schwierig ist.
Wir sind zu Besuch bei seiner Mutter
und seiner Schwester.
Bei den Dreharbeiten dort
ist Ilias Schori verzweifelt,
wütend, genervt, traurig.
Die Kamera
und die ständige Auseinandersetzung
mit seiner schwierigen Biografie
in den Schulen setzen ihm zu.
Genau wie
das Verhältnis zu seinen Eltern.
Ich hätte anders gehandelt, wenn ich
eine intakte Ehe gehabt hätte,
wenn ich noch Halt gehabt hätte.
Ich glaube,
das hätte extrem viel geholfen.
Und ...
Ilias war ja kein Einzelkind.
Da waren auch noch
vier kleinere Geschwister.
Und ...
Ich war sonst schon überfordert.
Gerade als alleinerziehende Mutter
liegt der Fokus so auf einem,
dass man das Gefühl hat,
alle würden einen beobachten.
Ich war sicher
in vielem viel zu streng.
Ich dachte immer,
ich müsste ihnen zeigen,
dass ich das im Griff habe.
Es war mir aber
schon längst entglitten.
Überstreng zu sein
schadet den Kindern genauso
wie wenn man sie
einfach machen lässt.
Hätten Sie Hilfe gebraucht,
die Sie nicht erhielten? - Ähm ...
Ja, ich hätte Hilfe gebraucht.
Aber vielleicht in anderer Form.
Mir einfach ein Kind wegzunehmen ...
Es ging ja nicht anders ...
... aber das war nicht das Richtige.
Jeder hat seinen Rucksack zu tragen.
Bei den einen kriegt man das mit,
bei den anderen nicht.
Die einen tragen es im Stillen
und man weiss nichts davon.
Aber ...
Das war vielleicht seine Art,
zu rebellieren.
Mit diesen Hilferufen nach aussen.
Damit das vielleicht irgendwie
ankommt und gehört wird.
Wie haben Sie
unter der Situation gelitten?
Was ist Ihr Rucksack?
Ich erinnere mich gut daran,
dass ich die Spannung zu Hause
kaum aushielt.
Und ...
Ich bin undankbar ... äh ...
Ich bin wahnsinnig dankbar,
dass ich dort so gute Freunde hatte,
bei denen ich Rückhalt fand.
Die mich
auch von zu Hause ablenkten.
Ich war in der Freizeit
jeweils den ganzen Tag draussen,
damit ich die Spannung
nicht aushalten musste.
(Schluchzend)Super gemacht.
Nicht wahr, Schwesterchen?
Bist du zufrieden?
Ich bin immer traurig.
Ich bin von Natur aus
ein trauriger Mensch.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Entschuldigung.
Nein, ich war ein glückliches Kind.
Aber durch meine Heimerlebnisse usw.
wurde ich traurig.
Und ich bin auch heute
ein trauriger Mensch.
So blöd das klingt.
Viele Dinge gehen mir sehr nahe
und ich kann auch über sie weinen.
Aber im Endeffekt
bin ich nicht traurig darüber,
dass das
aus meiner Familie entstand.
Denn ich weiss, dass ich
selber dafür verantwortlich bin.
Ilias' Betroffenheit
hält auch am nächsten Tag an,
bei den Dreharbeiten
mit seiner Pflegefamilie.
Komm rauf, komm.
Mit 18 kam er
zu Matthias Welte und dessen Frau.
Kurz darauf brach Ilias
seine Lehre als Automechaniker ab.
Und er beging weitere Straftaten.
Seine Pflegeeltern
gaben ihn trotz alledem nicht auf.
Das
war wahrscheinlich Schoris Rettung.
So, der ist etwas hoch. Das ist gut.
Ah, super. Perfekt.
Herr Welte, wie würden Sie
Ihr Verhältnis zu Ilias beschreiben?
Wie würden Sie das charakterisieren?
Ich würde sagen ...
... vielschichtig. Eindrücklich.
Unmöglich,
das in einem Satz zu erklären.
Ich weiss noch - das war
ein Schlüsselpunkt für mich:
Mein Mann arbeitete
bei der Schulsozialarbeit.
Eines Tages
kam er nach Hause und sagte:
"Hey,
da gibt es einen Jugendlichen ..."
"... und ich würde dem gerne
uns als Familie anbieten können ..."
"... um ihm zu helfen
und ihn zu unterstützen."
Wir hatten
schon vorher solche Angebote
und wir hatten vorher schon
Pflegekinder.
Erst fragte ich mich,
ob wir das noch mal wollen.
Dann sagtest du, Matthias:
"Er hat einfach ein megagutes Herz."
Sie kennen ihn,
seit er zehn ist, oder?
Seit der 5. Klasse, ja.
Da war ich schon Sozialarbeiter.
Ilias war damals Fünftklässler.
Was mich so beeindruckte,
war die Tatsache,
dass du damals auf dem Schulareal
ein Verbot hattest.
Und ich fragte mich: "What?"
"Wie soll er in die Schule,
wenn er ein Verbot hat?"
Das hat mich wie ...
Ja, ich fand, das sei komisch.
Das erlebe ich beruflich
nicht alle Tage.
Das war der Kick-off dafür,
wie wir in Kontakt traten.
Ilias,
was bedeutet Ihnen Ihr Pflegevater?
Es gibt keinen Pflegevater.
Das ist für mich eine Familie.
Er ist für mich ... Ähm ...
Er ist eine Person, die mir sehr
viel beigebracht und gegeben hat.
Ähm ...
Privat und familiär,
wie aber auch ...
... an meinem heutigen Punkt,
in dem Job, den ich mache.
Ich durfte viel von ihm lernen.
Warum sind Sie so gerührt?
- Er ist mein Vater.
(Schluchzend)
Ich kann das nicht erklären.
Ich ...
Weil das ein Teil von mir ist.
Weil das meine Familie ist.
Weil ich hier sein darf und ...
... hier den Dreh machen darf.
Weil es mich mitnimmt.
Ganz einfach. Weil es mich mitnimmt.
Das kam nicht von heute auf morgen.
Das war das Einzige,
was funktionierte.
Warum hat es hier funktioniert?
Weil ich Nestliebe kriegte.
Weil ich hier Geborgenheit kriegte.
Weil ich hier ich sein durfte.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ohne seine Pflegefamilie
hätte er den Weg aus der Kriminalität
nicht geschafft.
Doch dieser Weg bleibt hart
und steinig, sagt mir Ilias Schori,
gepflastert mit Schuldgefühlen
und Scham.
Aber ein Zurück
komme für ihn nicht infrage.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023